[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 78 voici les
titres de ce vendredi 27 novembre
notre invité aujourd'hui c'est didier
baichère député de la première
circonscription des yvelines
nous aborderons plusieurs sujets avec
lui notamment cette loi sécurité globale
mais également les annonces des manuels
macron sur la crise sanitaire et le
déconfinement en trois étapes et enfin
l'expérimentation du service d'accès aux
soins dans les yvelines
nous prendrons ensuite la direction du
parc zoologique de thoiry
les équipes continuent bien évidemment
de s'occuper des animaux
le parc est fermé au public depuis le 29
octobre
il espère une réouverture prochainement
enfin dans l'actualité sportive au
dernier pointage l'yvelinois 8 burton
est 8e au classement du vendée globe
comme chaque semaine nous ferons le
point sur son parcours
[Musique]
nous accueillons dj béchère bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes député la république
en marge de la première circonscription
des yvelines et nous allons aborder en
premier sujet cette loi dite de sécurité
globale plusieurs manifestations contre
cette loi sont d'ailleurs prévues ce
week end et en particulier c'est
l'article 24 qui pose problème alors
pour rappel cet article pénalise
notamment la diffusion malveillante de
l'image des policiers vous faites partie
des parlementaires qui ont voté pour à
l'assemblée nationale pourquoi alors je
crois qu'on est dans un moment où il
faut envoyer des signaux forts aux
forces de police qui ont été extrêmement
mobilisés ces derniers mois ces
dernières années et cet article 24 parce
qu'il ya d'autres choses dans leur dans
le texte de loi pourra sans dire un mot
rapidement mais cet article 24 il vise
finalement à renforcer le fait que si
vous aviez de l'image d'un policier à un
moment donné ou si vous vous aviez
d'intentions malveillantes à son
encontre en publiant des images parce
qu'on peut toujours évidemment filmé et
publier des vidéos vous pourriez avoir
dans ce cas là effectivement il ne peine
beaucoup plus importante que ce qui
existe aujourd'hui et je voudrais
rappeler à ceux qui nous écoutent que
c'est bien et m
évidemment le juge qui seraient
demandeurs d image et qui déciderait
dans une enquête si effectivement ces
images ont porté atteinte aux policiers
effectivement est pas le policier lui
même qui déciderait que les images
seraient à son encontre
et qu'en est il du floutage on en parle
beaucoup justement dans cette loi qu'en
est il du floutage des points ici il
n'est pas du tout prévu qui est un
floutage pense que cet article a cassé
un peu l'ensemble du travail de ce texte
de loi je rappelle que c'est une
proposition de députés ce n'est pas un
texte qui émane du gouvernement et qui
permet encore une fois d'organiser
beaucoup mieux le travail de la police
la coordination entre la police
gendarmerie la police municipale et les
sécurités privées et qui permet aussi
également un point qui est extrêmement
important et dans les évident on est
particulièrement concerné par ce qu'on a
participé aux expérimentations sur les
caméras piétons et sur les drones ou qui
permet d'encadrer ces nouvelles
technologies qui aujourd'hui font
l'objet d'expérimentations et qui n'ont
pas de cadre juridique pour protéger les
français de cette nouvelle technologie
mais pour protéger également les forces
de sécurité au moment de l'utilisation
de ces images d'une vidéo quand c'est
des caméras piétons ou drones qui permet
de surveiller un ca
deux manifestations en test aujourd'hui
dans le même temps que ce débat entre 4
que cette loi c'est controversé
deux événements ont eu lieu cette
semaine et la fin de semaine dernière
l'évacuation violente d'abord d'un
campement de réfugiés place de la
république à paris lundi soir dernier
selon l'igpn donc la police des polices
il ya notamment eu l' usage
disproportionné de la force et je cite
ans et leur enquête en tout cas qui est
ouverte contre un commissaire de police
notamment est le deuxième événement
c'était samedi dernier une intervention
de quatre policiers contre michel un
producteur de musique ça a été révélée
par nos confrères de l'outsider c'était
dans le 17e arrondissement à paris
et ces policiers sont aujourd'hui
suspendu et même en garde à vue ils vont
être entendu par l'igpn
tout cela a été filmé les images ont été
jugée violente autant par le président
de la république emmanuel macron que par
gérald darmanin le ministre de
l'intérieur ce qui a permis justement
aussi d'ouvrir des enquêtes
d'abord est-ce que ces images vous ont
choqué et également est ce que ces
images ne sont elles pas nécessaire avec
ce débat sur cette loi de sécurité
globale ces images de sont elles pas
nécessaire pour permettre ce débat
justement évidemment que ces images sont
choquantes maman je pense qu'il faut
insister fortement sur la présomption
d'innocence
moi je ne suis pas le juge qu'il ya que
le juge qui a été saisie effectivement à
la demande du ministre est immédiatement
d'ailleurs qui a fait une suspension
conservatoire des fonctionnaires de
police qui on pouvait voir sur sur ces
vidéos ont donc l'action elle était
immédiate bien sûr que c'est choquant
maintenant je pense qu'il faut faire
attention on est dans un pays où où
c'est le juge qui pourra décider si
effectivement ces policiers ont fauté et
s'ils ont fauté ils seront punis moi je
veux pas faire de raccourcis rapides ou
parce qu'on a vu des images en tirer des
conclusions je pense qu'il faut entendre
les policiers
il faut entendre la victime et que le
juge sereinement puisse faire son
travail et condamner les personnes et si
ces policiers ont effectivement
outrepassé leurs fonctions ici le
l'enquète le démontre ils seront exclus
de la police nationale bien évidemment
donc ces images qui ont été diffusées
par nos confrères de l'obs haider mais
également sur les réseaux sociaux par
d'autres confrères qui ont notamment
suivi l'évacuation de vue du camp de
réfugiés pour vous c'est pas ça rentre
pas dans l'article 24
pas du tout encore une fois cet article
24 il y là il a pour vocation à
permettre dans le cas d'une utilisation
malveillante à l'encontre
des forces de police il faut bien
comprendre que c'est à titre individuel
serre si on voulait porter atteinte à
l'intégrité
d'ailleurs il ya marqué porter atteinte
à l'intégrité exactement les trois mots
qu'il ya dans le texte
dans ce cas là la personne qui le ferait
dans ce but là seraient condamnés rien à
voir avec interdiction de filmer ou
obligés de flouter je sais pas quoi bien
évidemment que les journalistes doivent
continuer à faire leur travail
bien évidemment qu'on a besoin de ce
travail journalistique pour s'assurer
qu'il n'y ait pas de débordement puis
c'est tout simplement le fondement de
notre démocratie de pouvoir s'exprimer
librement
et ce texte de loi encore une fois il a
vocation à coordonner le travail de la
police et envoyés aussi un message de
soutien très fort à nos forces de police
qui encore une fois depuis des mois sont
sur le terrain on a eu l'épisode de
gilet jaune qui a été difficile et ils
ont toujours répondu présent et encore
une fois je pense que les françaises et
les français y soutiennent leur police
ils comprennent que c'est un métier
difficile
maintenant ça ne veut pas dire qu'il
faut faire n'importe quoi quand on est
détenteur de cet uniforme qui représente
ma technique très bien passons à un
autre sujet cette semaine c'était aussi
évidemment les annonces du président de
la république emmanuel macron sur la
crise sanitaire
il nous a présenté un des confirmands en
trois étapes la première c'est ce samedi
28 novembre et la réouverture des
commerces dits non essentiels par
exemple je cite les libraires pour vous
c'était une bonne solution ces trois
étapes
un petit point de sémantique on n'est
pas en déconfinement dire vous aurez pas
entendu ni le président ni le premier
ministre parlait de déconfinement on est
dans un assouplissement du confinement
ce qui n'a rien à voir on est toujours
confiné il y aura le couvre-feu on en a
jusqu'au 20 janvier voilà donc il ya
plusieurs étapes
bien sûr bien sûr quand même un
déconfite oui mais pour l'instant ce
n'est pas le cas on aura encore le
couvre-feu et on doit continuer bien
évidemment à utiliser l'ensemble des
gestes barrières levantes on a eu
l'habitude d'employer oui c'était
important fin jeudi ce qui nous guide
c'est la situation sanitaire je voudrais
rappeler quand même quelques chiffres
dans les yvelines ses 1600 décès que
nous avons depuis le début de cette
épidémie
quinze mille en ile-de-france et 50
mille morts en france donc c'est une
épidémie qui est extrêmement importante
on a vu que les chiffres s'améliorer
même si les services d'urgence dans les
yvelines sont encore
encore saturé donc il faut que chacun
soit responsable et progressivement
reprennent une vie j'ai envie de dire
normal il ya les fêtes de fin d'année
qui vont arriver donc c'était important
aussi pour les commerçants de pouvoir
réaliser le chiffre d'affaires via
beaucoup de commerçants qui réalise
jusqu'à 50% de leur chiffre d'affaires
au moment des faits je voudrais dire au
passage aussi ils ont été soutenus et
aidés dans les yvelines juste un chiffre
il ya 14 millions qui ont été consacrés
à l'aide directe des artisans et des
commerçants
ça représente à peu près de 17000
commerçants et artisans donc bien sûr il
travaille pas pour avoir des aides
publiques
ils ont ils ont besoin d'exercer leur
métier et c'est un peu le signal qui a
été envoyée donc on va progressivement
jusqu'à la rentrée de janvier
essayer de reprendre cette vie normale
et puis on espère avoir le vaccin qui
prendra la suite
très rapidement la troisième étape en
tout cas annoncé parce que c'est bien
pour le déconfinement à partir du 15
décembre on serait un couvre-feu et donc
tu en confinement la troisième étape
donc c'est le 20 janvier avec notamment
la réouverture des restaurants et des
bars tout cela uniquement si la
situation sanitaire évolué dans le bon
sens ça le président l'a bien rappelé
est-ce que c'est pas un peu prématuré de
déjà parler de cette 3e étape puisque le
20 janvier ça reste encore loin
est ce que savait pas un faux espoir
pour les restaurateurs et les les
patrons de bars mais c'est pour ça que
c'est important que chacun mesure bien
sa responsabilité individuelle si
pendant les fêtes de noël ont fait des
grands rassemblements familiaux comporte
pas le masque même à l'intérieur quand
on est avec sa famille on aura
inévitablement une nouvelle un nouveau
pic en fait de l'épidémie au milieu du
mois de janvier donc c'est pour ça qu'on
a donné cette date du 20 janvier
si on est raisonnable et qu'on fait
extrêmement attention qu'on continue à
ouvrir les fenêtres à porter le masque à
se laver les mains et à faire surtout
ces règles de distanciation
normalement les choses devraient
s'améliorer et s'il n'y a pas de
nouveaux pics dans ce cas là la date du
20 janvier est une bonne date pour
reprendre l'ouverture des commerces des
bars et donc de l'ensemble de l'activité
vous appelez donc les français à être
vigilants pendant les fêtes que les
restaurateurs et les bars puisse ouvrir
aussi le 20 janvier notion d'accord
d'être solidaire donc il faut on est on
est à un moment donné ou à cette
pandémie elle touche tout le monde de la
même manière donc il faut qu'on prenne
chacun notre part de responsabilité et
on l'a vu honnêtement sur le port du
masque de choses ont beaucoup progressé
par rapport au premier
confiné dernier sujet que nous allons
aborder ensemble
il est plus locale cette fois ci on
revient dans les yvelines un petit peu
le ministre de la santé olivier vers en
a retenu 22 site pilote pour
expérimenter dès janvier 2020 le service
d'accès aux soins qu'on appelle le sas
si j'ai bien compris le projet et des
yvelines porté par le centre hospitalier
de versailles le chv et la pta 78 a été
retenue
rapidement en quoi ça consiste qu'est ce
qui est important c'est toute la
transformation de notre système de soins
on a deux chiffres un pur donc ça touche
les urgences particulièrement en vingt
ans on a doublé le nombre de
fréquentations aux urgences on a mesuré
que plus de 40% de ses déplacements aux
urgences ne sont pas justifiées donc il
faut redonner aux urgences la réalité de
leur travail c'est très travaillé sur
l'urgence vitale et tout ce qui est du
suivi de maladies chroniques ou de la
bobologie le renvoyer vers la médecine
de ville vers les maisons de santé donc
le sas c'est un remplacement progressif
et une modernisation du 15 aujourd'hui
quand vous appeler le 15 pour vous
rendre aux urgences
vous avez simplement oui ou non en
fonction du diagnostic du médecin qui
est au téléphone avec le saas vous aurez
une orientation c'est à dire qu'on sera
capable de vous dire
pas besoin d'aller aux urgences par
contre vous avez ce médecin généraliste
qui est disponible qui peut vous
recevoir à telle heure où cette
infirmière ou ce kiné etc etc
donc c'est une vraie plateforme de
connexion de l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé sur le secteur
des yvelines en particulier dans le sud
yvelines qui va permettre de fait cette
orientation et éviter d'aller encombrer
les urgences et d'empêcher les
professionnels de santé à l'hôpital de
travailler sereinement
une expérimentation du coup je le
rappelle à partir de janvier 2021
merci d ib cher d'avoir été exclu sur ce
plateau
[Musique]
nous vous en parlions la semaine
dernière chaque mercredi depuis le 18
novembre et ce jusqu'au 9 décembre des
unités du raid s'entraîne dans le
bâtiment de la société
ces développements à montigny le
bretonneux le bâtiment est destiné et
pardon à être détruit prochainement
c'est pourquoi il est mise à disposition
du groupe d'intervention spécialisés de
la police nationale qui compte 450
personnes en france
nicolas landry est allé voir comment se
déroulent ces entraînements immersion
ici il n'ya pas de terroristes le
premier terroriste y aura sera au
premier étage juste au dessus une prise
d'otage par plusieurs terroristes voilà
le scénario principal de cet exercice
pour les unités du raid première phase
la préparation et la mise en place des
éléments par l'équipe de formation
certains vont jouer le rôle des
terroristes avec des consignes pour se
rapprocher au plus près des situations
réelles
le but c'est que la protection c'est
l'otage
élie desbin que de d'engager le feu sur
les forces de l'ordre
quand tu vois qu'ils arrivent tu te
prépare psychologiquement et tu viens
sur eux ici tout en engageant boum boum
boum boum boum éventuellement pendant ta
course un peu la feta deuxième grenade
et tu viens sur eux en kamikaze s'était
de la façon de procéder de de ces gens
là donc autant faire en exercice pour
les préparer au mieux pendant quatre
semaines chaque mercredi le raid dispose
de ce bâtiment propriété de la société
ini monteyne cfc développement il va
être détruit le groupement
d'intervention spécialisés de la police
nationale peut s'exercer dans des
conditions optimales ce site pour nous
aider grande importance parce que parce
qu'on peut sans on peut aussi entraîner
dans des conditions qui nous rapproche
de la réalité
donc ils peuvent
soient utilisées un calibre 12 soit
éventuellement une micro charge
explosive puisqu'ils vont considérer que
la porte est fermée à clé si je vois
qu'un opérateur se met en danger
l'équipe et qui présentent des blessures
et ben je peux sortir une fiche et
l'accrocher à l'individu et lui demander
de se mettre au sol dans cet exercice 25
opérateurs du raid divisés en deux
équipes d'aso vont participer tout le
monde est en place l'entraînement peut
commencer
[Musique]
créé en 1985 le raid est rattachée au
ministère de l'intérieur résolution de
prise d'otage à l'arrestation
d'individus dangereux protection de
personnalités les unités interviennent
sur ce type de situation les
entraînements sont hebdomadaires
on va avoir affaire à des gens qui vont
être très déterminé en phase avec un
risque de mort ils ont des explosifs
ils ont des armes à feu la moindre
petite erreur pour nous de placement
peut entraîner des blessures ou la mort
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
sommes s'entraînent très régulièrement
ils répètent des schémas tactiques
constamment pour être le plus efficace
possible
lors d'une crise le raid est implanté
dans dix sites en france métropolitaine
et trois bases dans les outre-mers 450
personnes sont engagées dans ce
groupement d'intervention spécialisés de
la police nationale on prend maintenant
la direction du parc zoologique de
thoiry
la structure est fermé depuis le 29
octobre date du début du 2ème
confinement mais les équipes sont
présentes tous les jours sur place pour
s'occuper des animaux en espérant une
réouverture courant décembre
reportage de michael elle me trouve un
soleil automnal se lève ce mardi 24
novembre sur touahri depuis près d'un
mois aucun visiteur ne peut se rendre
dans le parc zoologique à cause du
second confinement une situation inédite
qui n'a pas l'air de perturber les 1500
animaux du parc et en particulier pas de
changement déjà au prochain confinement
on n'avait pas vu grand chose de spécial
au niveau du changement des
comportements
non vraiment il s'en fiche un petit peu
nos animaux ils font leur petit footing
ya pas de problème pour eux pas de
bouleversement non plus pour les 25 à 30
personnes qui travaillent chaque jour
sur le site
évidemment la vie continuait à thoiry
des animaux même si elles confinement il
faut continuer de s'en occuper
même s'il n'y a pas les visiteurs pour
venir les voir il faut les nourrir
nettoyer l'horloge et à faire en sorte
que tout aille bien pour eux si le
quotidien des animaux et des soignants
n'est pas bousculer les gros changements
sont à observer du côté des allées du
parc vide
monde depuis le 29 octobre après une
belle fréquentation lors de la saison
estivale ce nouveau confinement est un
coup dur pour les recettes et surtout la
programmation du mois de novembre une
période un peu creuse maintenant depuis
trois ans maintenant on a lancé le
festival des lanternes qui nous permet
justement de toucher un public un peu
plus large sur l'hiver et moi météo
dépendons puisque la balade se prolonge
en début de soirée avec des
illuminations féeriques dans les jardins
du château
la direction du zoo espère pouvoir
recommencer le festival des lumières
d'ici la fin de l'année si le
gouvernement le permet en attendant le
parc vous propose de suivre le quotidien
des animaux depuis votre canapé sur ces
réseaux sociaux
un petit mot de voile comme vous le
savez en illinois louis burton
originaire de rambouillet participent à
cette édition 2020 du vendée globe le
skipper de 78 actuellement au sud de
l'océan atlantique
en face de l'argentine après trois
semaines de course à bord de son bureau
vallée 2 il est pour l'instant à la
huitième place du classement général
désormais les navigateurs vont bientôt
entrer dans des zones avec des
températures plus fraîches
on écoute le skipper aura bien tout
comme l'année mais autrement donc et
l'avantagent la de ces quelques noms de
bien fait chez tout le bateau bricole
donc pas fait chouette on allons
empêcher le bateau je suis tombé sur mon
sac cadeau
donc maintenant je fais pour mes cadeaux
pour noël est en effet les feux de
l'actualité de la semaine c'est grégory
canale qui vous la résume en 78 secondes
la levée progressive du confinement se
fera en trois étapes a annoncé emmanuel
macron la première dès samedi 28
novembre avec notamment la réouverture
des commerces dits non essentiels
chargement vent devant le tribunal de
versailles le 7 décembre l'ex préfet des
yvelines de 2015 à 2018 comparaîtra pour
des accusations de détournement de fonds
publics et faux documents
alors qu'il était encore en fonction
l'enquète avant sur l'assassinât de
samuel pas tjrs à conflans sainte
honorine quatre nouveaux collégiens ont
été mises en examen cette semaine dont
trois pour complicité d'assassinats
terroristes
36e campagne d'hiver des restos du coeur
lancé en pleine crise sanitaire et
économique
les 26 centres du territoire s'attendent
à recevoir des bénéficiaires
supplémentaires cette année
manifestation ce 26 novembre à
versailles d'une cinquantaine d'agents
du secteur social et médico social
ces personnes s'estiment oubliés du
ségur de la santé elles demandent entre
autres une hausse de 183 euros de leur
salaire mensuel cinquième édition du sky
business dès cette année en 100% virtuel
la convention d'affaires de saint
quentin en yvelines a réuni 400
entreprises et 500 participants
et puis 50 ans neeve une personne ancien
vice président à la culture pierre celle
en cours c'était 1 à 4 dans trois ans il
a été le maire communiste de la verrière
pendant 29 ans jusqu'en 2012
un hommage lui sera rendu prochainement
[Musique]
pour terminer ce journal patrice
carmouze directeur de l'information de
tv sont 18 à rencontrer un libraire de
fontaine le fleury sur la réouverture de
son commerce ce samedi 28 novembre
un entretien enregistré mercredi 25
novembre j'arrive maximilien bonjour
vous êtes libraire à fond de fleury la
librairie je me souviens alors donc on a
appris hier par la bouche des manuels
makoko les librairies allez pouvoir ré
ouvrir c'est parce que c'est pour vous
un soulagement
ah oui tout à fait c'est sûr que après
ce mois de confinement et les deux mois
qui ont été au printemps également c'est
vrai que c'est une c'est une belle
nouvelle qu'on puisse rouvrir dès samedi
ça change quand même le le rapport au
livre le fait de rouvrir une librairie
parce que quand on fait le click and
collect go vasile click and collect un
oui tout à fait on faisait le click and
collect mais c'est vrai que c'est pas du
tout autre métier on n'est pas comment
dire non intentionnelle et on n'est pas
on n'est pas des gens qui sommes en
permanence sur internet
nous notre métier c'est de pouvoir
rencontrer des lecteurs de pouvoir
discuter avec eux de pouvoir
en discutant avec connaître leurs goûts
et leur présenter des livres qui
correspondent à ce qu'il souhaite et
leur fair envie aussi sur des livres
connu et te défendre donc c'est ça un
autre métier ah oui c'est ça ses
conseillers le lecteur au point de vue
chiffre d'affaires est ce que ce
confinement est très impactant pour
voler pour les libraires oui t'as pas vu
oui bien sûr
derniers mois de l'année pour la
librairie c'est 30% du chiffre
d'affaires donc notamment le mois de
décembre qui est le plus important donc
fermé à ce moment là c'est très
difficile pour nous il avait coûté on
espère que les clients vont se
précipiter dès l'ouverture dans vos
librairies je rappelle que vous êtes
donc libre et la fontenelle florrick la
librairie s'appelle je me souviens merci
beaucoup je relise maximilien merci à
vous c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi l'information revient
lundi à 18h dans le 7-8 journal présenté
par grégory canale mais avant cela vous
pourrez revoir toutes nos émissions sur
le site internet tv 78 points comme et
notre application mobile tv 78 et d'ici
là je vous souhaite un excellent
week-end et une très bonne soirée
[Musique]